hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to other
edition of ask Evan today I'm going to
answer a question from one of my readers
KATU who wrote in saying that wanted to
sort of business but wasn't sure how to
do it or where to start so some quick
advice for you I always start with the
why so why are you starting your
business what are you really passionate
about you want to build a wrestle thing
that you have a really strong interest
in you're not just trying to make a lot
of money which is great and will happen
if you're really you know doing
something valuable but you want to start
about something that you're super
passionate about so tap into your skills
tap into what you're really excited
about where if you can help a lot of
people and that's where you want to kind
of get started with your business the
next thing I would do is think about
potential customers you can help and the
best way to build a business is around
the customer who has a problem who you
can help solve that problem they're
willing to pay you for so before I spend
a lot of money creating your business
and promoting it start talking to
potential customers so whatever posture
identified that you feel you can help
people up with ghosts are talking to
people who can potentially pay you to
solve a problem for them and build your
product or service around those issues
so you get close to your customer and
you have money coming in quickly write a
lot of companies do the wrong thing they
start off with a great idea that they
think is a great idea and they launch it
spend a lot of money and nobody wants to
buy it or they would buy it if it had
these tweaks so you spend a lot of time
and effort and money going down the
wrong road before you start listening to
your customers so better to start
talking to customers before you start
your business and build it around the
paint customer as much as you can as you
grow the amount of money that you're
going to make is going to be importunate
how much value provide so the more you
can help people the more value can bring
them more you're going to get paid then
when you get to make solely that helps
is a quick starter start around what
you're really excited about where you
cannot allow the value start talking to
customers and get their feedback and
build it around someone who has a pain
and the drilling the solvent and willing
to hire you and pay you money to solve
it for them
and then remember that how much money
you're going to make is going to be
directly related to how much you value
you bring it how much you help people so
over that helps if you guys like the
video please give it a thumbs up below
and I'd love to hear you have to think
if you wanna leave a comment under the
video or you have some advice for cat to
as well thank you and we'll see you in
the next episode
you